(silence)
Skrattar... Förlorar Mannan
Hej allihopa vad trevligt att träffas er.
(Hello everyone! Nice to meet you.)
Nu är det så att om du skrattar så förlorar du.
(Now, if you laugh, you lose.)
very well
the contract as been sealed let's begin the challenge
of skrattar du förlorar du
Today we have the sports editon
Thats right
Sports are so funny
I cant stop laughing
Sorry i was just thinking about sports
Let's do the sports edition of skrattar du förlorar du
thats a definitely a good idea
jesus
oh my god
damn wamen dont play around
that is not skrattar that is concerna
meanwhile men playing football
why is football (voice) "known as soccer"
just the lamest sport of all time
thanks to this sort of thing
sports is just so stupid
does anyone actually watch sports unironically?
you know how old people are like why would you watch someone else play a video game
(Gibberish)
why would you watch sports then
thats like 10 times worse
dont get it
what am i supposed to do then, huh
he became a ball
damn
wrestling sure is tough
This is literally me anytime i get in a fight with someone.
Caption me as the ball, and the wrestler as my responsibilities
And you got yourself an epic tumblr gif right there.
Oh, i almost Skrattar
Sorry, sorry. I was just thinking about gifs (with j)
Gifs, i thought about gifs
So funny.. they just make me laugh. Almost as funny as sports.
Is all of these without sound, like what the heck?
Zero, three
Oh here comes the tears.
Oh no my team is losing.
It keeps happening.
Oh yes
Zero, Five?! Zero, Six
When did this happen?
Jesus
Oh my god
You're crying.
Pathetic
Oh my god
Why are they crying?
(mocking voice) You don't get it man, you just don't care about sports.
Huh, i guess i don't. Jesus Christ Pathetic
Alright the sports idea clearly isn't worth it
Aaa...
Just gonna get a lot hate
From you scumbags
Who thinks sports is cool
I bet you I can beat you in any sports
I’ll have you know I’m extremely athletic
Cuckold, a cuckold is a man
whose wife is promiscuous to his face
and everybody knows.
Exactly, exactly.
Um, in this particular scene um
This is a
a genre of film?!
Uh yeah! Yeah, very popular genre.
Um, like I said I've done several of these
Have you played the cuckold?
I was just recognized for the award
at the AVN awards for best uhhh cuckold.
Um uhh
And uh in this particular scene
my wife is uh shaming me-
Who - now who plays your wife?
Oh uh, my actual wife.
That's Debbie?!
Yeah. You can't see with the-
you can't see her entire face
uh, it's a, he's a pretty big guy
Wait a minute, wait a minute
There's an African American man-
(Laughs)
That can’t be real
That must have been a sketch
That's so good
Have you Skrattar yet?
Let me know in the comments right now
Maybe the sports bit was a bit too much for youu..
I know
We have some pretty funny clips here
I'm basically the new Ray William Johnson
But at least I don't throw a black baby around
That bit was hilarious
Oh you don't believe me?
Sive is editing right now
And he's literally shaking in anger
I know sive this is some pretty outrageous racism
Can't believe it
For my favorite YouTuber Ray William Johnson
Who inspired me to create this show myself
By laughing at funny clips
I love it
I just love it
I mean I hate it
It's upsetting
That's what I meant
Sorry..
I got it all mixed up
Okay.. alright.. you ta.. you talking to me?
Oh I didn't recognize him
I bet brad.. brad is so into D&D
He would love this soo..
Brad: Hi everybody
Brad: Its me Brad Woto
Brad: We started a D&D sort of collaborative effort...
(Brad being cut off mid sentence)
I.. I feel like brad would appreciate this one
(Laughs)
Sports and D&D they are equally bad
That's just how it is
(Long silence)
(Still keep going)
(Almost there...)
(Just a little more)
Sorry
(clears throat)
Next clip everyone..
This is Australian Rick and Morty?
Yup..
Rick and Morty summarized everyone
There you go
Fantastic..
Is this official?
That's the Adult Swim on it
That's awesome
If it is
(She is deaf, as she never listen to anything she dosent know how to speak... or sing)
(Mating call of the Beluga Whale)
(Mating call of the Beluga Whale continues...)
(Mating call of the Beluga Whale is still going on strongly)
(How she is singing something she never listen to? it's because the music comes from her soul)
What is happening?? (no clue)
(Crying sound of a Blue Whale dying)
What is going on?? (idk)
(The Dying sounds of a Dog :( continues)
How is this real?? (¯\_(ツ)_/¯)
The sounds of the Dinosaurs when they met their fate.
(Laughs? Or in pain? Or Both?)
(The sounds of a death woman singing a song)
(Clapping Proud)
That was beautiful..
(Continues Clapping Proud)
What.. in the world?
I feel like someone is gonna explain to me in the comments
And they are gonna be like
"Excuse me Felix she's suffering from bla blalah and I can't believe you’re so insensitive"
Like what am I.. I.. what is this?
I don't know!
They are speaking crazy language!
Eastern European countries are so weird..
..you don't know what's happening.. (voice cracks)
Is it edited?! I don't know?
Let's watch that one again..
This is one.. just one more quick little watch..
I feel like I'm going crazy (Same)
I don't..
I can't..
I can't explain what..
I don't want to see that ever again
Fine..
Okay..
You made me chuckle..
What do you want?
(Laughs)
Jesus Christ..
Jesus!
Its terrifying
Oh thank god..
Great..
I feel like now I know
How I'm going to die
Look good!
(Felix slowly dying inside)
("Why are we still here, just to suffer")
Now I know..
How I'm going to die..
(I predicted it.. wow)
That is genuinely..
Terrifying.. (Agree)
(Reads comment on screen)
(The expression of "A VERY BAD IDEA")
Ehhh...
(mocking voice) Screw it I'm gonna do it.. (Your gonna regret it)
(mocking voice) I don't care about the consequences (Soon you will)
Okay..
Oh my god..
Are you ready? (no)
(Please take off your headphones for your safety)
(The sound of suffering souls)
(RIP headphone users..if any)
(This is geting out of hand)
(Sorry to HEAR that)
Ooo..
Oooo..
Oooo...
Oooo yes..
Yes..
(Copying the men in the clip)
(Looks painful..)
(Copying the men in the clip but in pain)
(It goes on forever..)
(Copying the men in the clip but in pain, part 2)
(Copying the men in the clip but laughing instead)
What is happening?? (No idea)
I'm scared (You should be)
I'm confused (So am I)
This whole episode (So am I)
It started off with sports.. (We know)
What is happening??
Please..
No..
I don't want anymore nightmares.. (Same)
Please..
(Finally stopped.. thank god)
Goddammit..
That's it for this week..
Skrattar du förlorar du
It was a wide range of emotions (Sure was)
But we made it through everybody (Thank god for that)
So make sure you leave a like if you skrattar..
And a like if you förlorar (So either way it doesn't matter)
And I will see you next time (Ofc you will)
Goodbye (Bye..)